he's Bryan Cranston the movie is the
infiltrator opens Wednesday July 13th
and Bryan plays an undercover federal
agent infiltrates the drug cartel taking
down the largest drug and money
laundering operation in US history and
he joins us now good morning Brian how
are you Dan 610 105 by the way I'm
getting thinner but taller how are you
man I'm good I'm good
what kind of athlete were you I know you
like baseball but were you good athlete
I was good enough you know I played
sports all the way through the years and
when I got to high school I realized you
know what I think I'm just not quite
that good at us yeah and when I didn't
have a although I wanted to be a
baseball player the worst way and I was
in the worst way it didn't work out to
it but I loved the game more than I was
good at it and and then I went to Dodger
fantasy camp and played in an adult
baseball league for a while and until my
shoulder said no that's enough of that
do you have baseball memorabilia any
sports memorabilia I used to collect
some things along the way but I let it
all go I donated it to raise some money
for a charity so I don't have anything
else uh-uh
like lighten the load when you're right
now you're in New York right I am in New
York right now yet okay when you walk
down the street do you ever get somebody
who surprises you instead of saying
something about a I loved you as how or
Walter White or like something that's
really obscure yeah you know I get
Seinfeld references and I get Malcolm in
the Middle and I get definitely breaking
bad some woman said oh my god oh my god
oh and I'm and I think I always play a
game with I said okay so where does she
know me so I'm Breaking Bad probably she
owes you're not going to believe this
but I remember you I would come home
from school
and watch you on the soap opera loving I
have never heard that that was that was
you know well over 30 years ago that I
did that show and that was a shocker how
much does it help though getting famous
after the age of 40 as opposed to if you
got famous at 20 how would you have
handled I'd I don't know I wasn't famous
at 20 so I don't really know but I can
only imagine it would be almost like
having a child at 20 and I didn't I had
a child when I was 35 years old I think
and and I was a I think it was a better
dad because of it I was more mature I
didn't want to go out anymore I mean it
was like I you want different things and
I think that helped a lot so I think
it's probably the same that there's an
old Chinese proverb that wishes you
great success at a very young age and
it's intended to be a curse Wow
because to have it and lose it is
probably worse off I mean you know it's
funny because I never saw Fame I just
wanted to be make my living as an actor
if I can do that that's that's that's
everything to me and that still is my
proudest professional accomplishment is
that from age of 25
that's all I've done did you have any
concerns that you were so good at some
of these roles that they would stay with
you whenever somebody saw you that I
mean when I saw you as Walter White I
went on that's how and then it didn't
take long before I went I forgot all
about that and then you go and play LBJ
like to be able to do that and and have
people forget about what you were before
and that's that's a pretty daunting
challenge well that's probably the best
compliment I can get truly when someone
says I didn't even know was you as LBJ
and
or dalton trumbo or or in this movie the
infiltrator that I'm that comes out and
on window it is probably the best thing
I can hear because that means I've done
my job I've gotten into this character
and having a separate set of
characteristics for each character that
I could find and and hide away
he's Bryan Cranston the movie he was
talking about the infiltrator opening
Wednesday July 13 what attracted you to
this role my god this story is amazing
Bob maser is a real man a good family
man husband he's also a money launderer
for the Medellin Cartel but he's a
customs agent so he's infiltrating the
Medellin Cartel and over two and a half
years he is working undercover daily
facing tremendous odds danger at every
turn and what really got me is not just
that the plot is fantastic and intense
but at the end of the day he goes home
to his wife and his kids and becomes dad
it helps with homework and he takes the
trash out and stuff we all do and and
also he makes really really good friends
with some of these guys who are not all
bad and certainly not good and are
criminals and need to be arrested so at
the end of two and a half years you have
to betray the that friendship arrest
those people and do your best to send
them to jail so that's the thing that
really got me and Bob Mazur is is alive
and well helped out on this he's one of
the producers on this he had at our
premiere tonight in Manhattan and no one
will know it he still can't be
photographed because there's a concern
about reprisals and in a retribution so
it's he will be hiding in public what do
you say I imagine that Walter White is
the one that people say did you take it
home with you but it is there like Elbe
J to transform yourself like physically
into somebody that we know the role that
yet
you kind of couldn't shake or you
brought it home and your wife said leave
it at the door did you have one yeah you
know LBJ was fun because the the sexual
politics in the 60s were so permissive
for men so you know I just put on this
thing and I let come here darling let's
turn around let me look at your backside
you can wear that blouse and that skirt
more often that really sets you apart
you know and things like that you can
get away with that no and I would do
that kind of ad-libbing on the set just
to keep me loose and keep me in the
character but you know I could be sued
for that if you're actually doing that
now and my wife just you know she's been
tolerant for so many years
she's as rolls her eyes at those things
but yeah he did III made sure that I
didn't want to bring Walter White home
with me nobody wants to live with Walter
why did you get a Winnebago sponsorship
out of that I wasn't thinking at least a
tighty-whitey deal yes right like right
yes wouldn't through the looms or hang
yes didn't they say hey this is a slam
dunk I'm waiting for it dad if if Hanes
called
let's say Michael Jordan said hey Brian
would you shave your head and kind of
come back is Walter and we're will have
a Hanes underwear commercial for you the
the episode that you found yourself
actually watching whatever it was was it
Breaking Bad or you know was it how like
you've stopped yourself or somebody at
homes watching and you just say oh and
you settle in and watch a little bit
more than you probably thought you would
have you had that moment recently it it
has happened it happened about a couple
months ago I was in a hotel room and
unpacking I just checked in and I'm
unpacking and I slipped on I was looking
for ESPN and I'm kind of
flipping through and I see a rerun of
malcolm in the middle' and it's like oh
and I'm watching this and there's a
slight familiarity to it and yet if I
was asked at that moment what do you do
in this episode I wouldn't be able to
tell you it's like I don't know what I
did in this but I remember this it's
like a dream and I sat on the end of my
bed and watched this thing in in in some
familiar form and then it came to me and
I watched the whole episode and it was
like wow that really was a good show I
love that show
the racewalking one is still my favorite
I loved it because you gave left nothing
they were the imagination by the way
when you put that suit on there hey we'd
love to have you in studio one of these
days and wish you well with the movie I
saw the reviews they look awesome good
luck with the premiere coming up tonight
thank you Dad I appreciate it I do want
to come into the studio next time all
right Thank You Bryan good to talk to
you again thank you all right Bryan
Cranston the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience